Jane Austen is loved mainly as a guide
to a fashionable life in the Regency
period but her own vision of her task
was radically different
she was an ambitious and Stern moralist
she was acutely conscious of human
failings and wanted through her novels
to make people less selfish and more
reasonable more dignified and sensitive
to the needs of others born in 1775
Austen grew up in a small village in
Hampshire where her father was the
Anglican rector they had high social
status but were not well-off she did
much of her writing at a tiny octagonal
table she never married though on a
couple of occasions she was tempted
mostly she lived in the country with her
sister Cassandra the novel was her
chosen weapon in the struggle to reform
humanity she completed sex sense and
sensibility Pride and Prejudice
Mansfield Park
Emma Northanger Abbey and persuasion
some of the main things she wants to
teach you are in Pride and Prejudice mr.
Darcy and Elizabeth Bennet start off
heartily disliking each other and then
gradually realised they're in love they
make one of the great romantic couples
but why actually are they right for one
another Austen is very clear it's for a
reason we tend not to think of very much
today each can educate and improve the
other Darcy starts off feeling superior
because he has more money in higher
status then at a key moment Elizabeth
condemns his arrogance and pride to his
face it sounds offensive but later he
admits your reproof so well applied I
shall never forget you taught me a
lesson hard indeed at first but most
advantageous by you I was properly
humbled they suit each other because by
her ease and liveliness his mind might
have been softened his manners improved
and from his judgment information and
knowledge of the world
she must have received benefit of
greater importance in other words they
balance each other out we tend to think
of love as liking someone for who they
are already total acceptance but Austen
is saying that the right person has got
to be able to help us overcome our
failings
become more mature honest and kind and
we need to do something similar for them
Darcy and Elizabeth improve one another
and then the novelist lets them get
engaged the story rewards them because
they have developed well that's why the
novel feels so beautifully constructed
and it illustrates a basic truth
marriage depends on maturity and
education Mansfield Park starts when
quiet shy Fanny Price goes to live with
her much richer cousins the Bertram's
in social terms the Bertram the stars
and Fanny is a very minor character
indeed but Austen judges by a completely
different standard she exchanges the
normal lens through which people are
viewed in society a lens which magnifies
wealth and power for a moral lens which
magnifies qualities of character
suddenly Fanny has no elegant dresses or
money and can't speak French but by the
end of Mansfield Park she is revealed as
the noble one while the Bertram's
despite their titles and accomplishment
have fallen into moral confusion Austen
is quite frank about money in Pride and
Prejudice she explains that mr. Bingley
has an income of four thousand pounds a
year that's rather a lot while Darcy has
more than twice that rather than feeling
it's impolite to discuss money Austin
thinks is an eminently suitable topic
for highbrow literature because how we
handle our finances has a huge effect on
our lives
she takes aim at two big mistakes people
make around money the first is to get
over impressed by it in Mansfield Park
Julia Bertram gets married to mr.
Rushworth the richest character in all
of Austen's novels but they are
miserable together and their marriage
rapidly falls apart but equally Austen
is convinced that it's a serious error
to get married without enough money at
one point in Sense and Sensibility
it looks like Elinor Dashwood and Edward
Ferrars who are otherwise well suited
won't be able to get married
she writes they were neither of them
quite enough in love to think that 350
pounds a year would supply them with the
comforts of life Ellen er takes the view
that wealth has much to do with
happiness though by wealth she doesn't
mean great luxury
enough to live carefully in moderate
comfort and Austin agrees marriage
without a reasonable economic basis is
just a folly Austin is showing us an
elusive but crucial attitude money is in
some ways extremely important and in
other ways unimportant we can't just be
for it or against it in emeth the
heroine Emma herself takes Harriet Smith
a pretty girl from the village under her
wing she wants to make her an impressive
match with a smart vicar swept away by
Emma's excessive praise Harriet turns
down an offer of marriage from a farmer
because she thinks now that he's not
good enough though in fact he is
good-hearted and quietly prosperous then
the vicar turns out to be horrified at
Emma's idea and Harriet has her heart
broken the underlying point is serious
emma is unwittingly but cruelly snobbish
she's devoted to the wrong kind of
hierarchy the farmer is essentially a
better person than the vicar
but social conventions and manners make
it easy to ignore this Jane Austen is
careful to give this fault to Emma who
is in many ways an enchanting character
in other words Jane Austen doesn't mock
snobbery as the behavior of ghastly and
contemptible people instead she regards
the snob with pity as someone who is in
need of instruction guidance and reform
as we all are in our own way
Austen might have written sermons she
wrote novels instead she doesn't tell us
why her sense of priorities is important
instead she shows us in a story which
will also make us laugh which can grip
us enough that we want to finish supper
early to read on upon finishing one of
the novels were invited to go back into
the world and respond to others as she
has taught us to pick up on and recoil
from greed arrogance and pride and to be
drawn to goodness within ourselves and
others sadly the moral ambition of the
novel has largely disappeared in the
modern world yet it's really the best
thing that any novel can do the
satisfaction we feel when reading Jane
Austen is really because she wants the
world to be a certain way and we find
that immensely appealing it's the secret
largely unrecognized reason where she
is such a loved writer
you